sometimes I've taken a project that
seemed to be all lined up to be a hit
and managed to alienate the like the
Dana Carvey Show there's a famous
documentary on the Hulu channel on I
want to watch it what's it called to too
funny to fail and it's so Dana Carvey
was given a variety show at ABC 9:30 at
ABC 9:30 at ABC one of the funniest
shows who was just to talk about the ilk
of people that worked on that show so
it's Steve colar Steven Carell Steve
Carell
um uh uh Charlie Kaufman was one of the
writers Louis CK was the the producer
under me uh youo stamatopoulos brilliant
writer of uh it was like the who's who
of the writing staff was insane yeah and
then we also hired Carell and colar gave
them their first real TV jobs right you
know and then we had other funny people
in the cast so what's the what does the
documentary tell us the documentary just
Chronicles uh the High Hopes the show
had the the problem of of doing it on a
Disney own channel like you know immed
wasn't that thing at the beginning if I
remember I don't I I don't know that I
remember you had Clinton bre we we
basically killed the show with the very
first sketch we did was that the one I'm
talking about yes so so we had this
sketch where it started with Dana um was
playing Clint he did a very funny Clint
and he's talking about how um he was way
ahead not George Clinton President
Clinton President Clinton I know you
know that I do know Bill I'm I'm not not
going to condescend here President
Clinton she knows bill but not like not
like Monica there you go if you Monica
that's you go that's something this was
Prem Monica though anyway so Bill
Clinton had this thing where he used to
say I feel your pain that was his
catchphrase and um Hillary at this time
was very unpopular I don't know this was
March of 1996 I don't remember even the
circumstance but Hillary was like
bringing his poll numbers down so he
sets it up like saying Hillary has been
placed in a facility and we cut to it
and she's like Rabbid and banging
against the doors and trying to get out
and then I'm going to be both you know I
am the feeling president I I will be
both the the father and mother to this
country and then um I don't remember
that was Louis's premise and he he said
something like I have developed the
ability with the help of science to
breastfeed and then he pulls out a
nipple and starts
breastfeeding I think a child I think we
had a real child in there I can't
remember maybe it was a doll this is on
ABC Disney own on ABC and it was a real
it wasn't a real child it was a doll is
there not a c of this we'll see we'll
cut it in as you're saying it go ahead
so that was maybe maybe we would have
been fine but then I had to interject I
was obsessed with animals you may know
between Triumph and yeah a lot of other
stuff I've done I was like what if he's
also what if he is that how you wait
wait what if he's also what if he also
has the ability to uh what if he has
eight nipples that was my thing yeah you
just had he have eight nipples and then
we start bringing puppies and kittens in
and everybody's like hilarious so we did
it on ABC buy I watched it I I was
laughing hysterically I was on the floor
here's the thing I didn't understand
that Home Improvement which was the lead
in it was the number one show on
television and I didn't understand that
it was like a family show that kids and
parents watched together right it was on
at 9 it wasn't in the family hour Tim
Allen you know had a history of you know
dealing Coke or whatever he had like a
he had this dark side that I thought oh
and then Pam Anderson was on the show
right so I didn't think of it I didn't I
never watched it you thought it was coke
and porn I didn't not quite but I
thought it was Prime Time version of
coke and porn whatever that was see my
take is you thought it was a family show
that's why you had babies and animals
sucking
on if only I had if I had only had a
strategy of some sort but I didn't I was
just like this is funny wait wait it's
funny and Louie
crazily said you know what's great about
this idea is going to draw a line in the
sand you're either with us or you're not
and it's like that's the last thing you
want to do on Prime Time television on
your first show like yeah let's alienate
half the audience and I was like yeah
yeah rock and roll we were so naive and
then it wasn't literally till like four
weeks in that I watched an episode of
Home Improvement and I was horrified I
was like what have I done to Dana
carvey's career how did I not watch this
show in the making of In in the the
ideas did the network not see script oh
yeah they saw everything so no they were
behind it everybody at ABC was cool with
it except one guy David Weston he was
the head of like news at the time or
something he was way higher up and he
was really angry about it but all the
other Executives they don't say this in
the in the show in the in the
documentary they pret that they were
like outraged by and that we fought them
but no it was only this one guy David
Weston who and then by the way like
within a year everyone else had been
fired except for David Weston he was a
pretty smart guy apparently but um yeah
no they they were totally for it and the
sponsor we also had this gimmick we
called it the Taco Bell Dana Carvey Show
that was Dana's idea like CU in the old
days in like the' 40s be like Texico
Star Theater well she knows it's it's
like like YouTube now yeah they sponsor
you can integrate your your uh product
with whatever the show is you don't
think that's like podcast too yeah yep
well he's yeah yeah that so the
sponsor's name used to be on television
show so Dana thought it would be funny
that we would change it every week so
Taco Bell was the first week and they
love the sketch they had no notes the
second the sketch aired and there were
all these letters coming in they were
like we apologize we had nothing to do
we didn't know and and then we the next
week we had a new sponsor because that
was the plan this was like Mug Root Beer
or something and everybody thought oh no
Taco Bell pulled out pulled out that's
why I thought it was a sponsor yeah no
everybody thought that we lost our
sponsor so just everything it was a
Murphy's Law
situation oh but it's that like when
when the stars align like the fact is I
don't think in my in my uh history in
Show Business have I ever seen a lineup
of on camera and behind the scene people
that illustrious that equipped and fail
so brilliantly abruptly but but but it
was very loud it's so much so that it's
a it's a Hulu documentary now know we
there were spectacular Flames that we
went up in
yeah
B